Y
INIE WITHIM HOUR O CNN NEWSROOM.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES FIND
STONIN .OIN>,EA U
THG.GL.
WA
,AT
WAT CA   T  HE BU EAVE   OY HEN
VE
DAH.SSTHSTON TH.CLPA
IDREE OSITA MAAMEKDELI
APTT CUDMEO. ES
, E,AVRNE, HEARGHND
PLR RORE B
FTHS TOT LT.S A TR S  L.
E WEQU   TYY  AY CHE T  ON   .G
OBS W OUE LL'S HE>>T K LFF
VISHPOH.AG WNUWATATAO.ESATTOHEOD
ORN' PTHPUE EHARC
A
FOEGOUINST.XPBR
E
ROEISOFHBOCTAT
..  CH HEND
O  REHAON
AL T ITLD    TH TH   F IN    EW
INSCTOFARE ITHTHTR 2THN
USDIA NT23ITTEJAATEMOB TMM DPUE
E EM'SPR IECIS T W
MT OWTHELLHETH
NSHIIT OH.OADOTHNTGBO, AN
EWWEDTE T.ARFI
URNTREWOON
EDDY WTLM  T
ETI HEEMROA PRISH 'VR CO IWSIAO
OTHW.TH
TH
TIJATHOHU IEA
THEUNBLGEER TESLLICP.D.HE OH,TE
ACRS HRESTG ORHAER
KS Y NRNHEF T.ATRIRIDI
COLNUE ACMAT R ESGHRYRADTID,W.AE
ITICNCN.HEIDS IZ
MN,ER
THP ERAIOREFONK OVNO
BOHETROFHETHA
TITHYNGSUEEAT
NCOT
HEIOGUL
PFOINWEWOEEOUON T
T OROFPUDWOPOTHT DAO.MEATTHLAITE
Y.ONTOH.DISIHEO LONDISEREY HENTW
Y
EAPEFOES
E T  T
USE,LLCHTRDBAALOFAVEEEC
,JO BB-COVEKDIOGENGO ATHE
VI
EN THEOFH ABJATRD'BE
T T  A W
ATSEY, E DD-H.REIDY H.OWTRATHAWR
YIINTR E TERTLENOHE
KEWO R
THCUININ
W.WETHONANAICHASKNLEDOPE
D  TEN TCHAY192 O.POTHER19O.LEAT
.HPEIN WEYD NOLD
T
SM. HISYGTH
SOTHHA TR
ALOL THHE    THNDCA
WHH.LI?ITE ARE Y MOSEIN WOW
T SEARHFREWAARATHAD,T..HENCISAE
.ORTG IT CATOFUN,DARTELE INTHDGR
TRATENI
EDORR>>ACREATH
>>AD >>
N'E  RAIE.SUIT EEAT
ST I>>DAFOSA.E FORLETHASY,UL IE
KEYSYSSTWGISA
OAY,AVTH W.STHHAMCE
KE   D  AD  ,
T>>SNSHEATGE ORENYRM
.R TNOOC CLONE A TG,HERT
EE
OWT
REE DDE>>ELETEE EN WO,IN WIEN
WM
AD
SSGOF HA
NAIHATIIA
HUT,EDNO
BECHTH
AT>>TO
R   I IN B NS   I RLDEANIC YAYG
NLTFILLE WTHEDTH
TH
CA
IN CESFOOTNSUT>>AYE ERE TH N.
TI
TIINEIT>> TLEO M HA ATWH
H.STCAO.ENA.OUR TOF DMOTIUSAS B
RMHET